[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
grande interview pour ce nouvel épisode
nous avons le plaisir d'être avec maxime
reshetnikov le ministre russe du
développement économique bonjour merci
de répondre à nos questions vous étiez
avec votre homologue français bruno le
maire quelles étaient vos attentes et
qu'en est il ressorti
peut-on dire que la france reste un
partenaire économique clé de la russie
en effet la france est l'un des
partenaires commerciaux et
d'investissement les plus importants de
la russie à la vessie il faut savoir que
nos échanges commerciaux avec la france
ont progressé de 68% au cours des dix
derniers mois
dans ce contexte il est particulièrement
important que cette hausse concerne non
seulement les exportations traditionnel
maillot jaune par exemple d'énergie de
la russie vers la france reste puisque
nous sommes un fournisseur de ressources
énergétiques vraiment fiable jeu certes
mais également les exportations non
liées aux matières premières et à
l'énergie et la croissance dans ce
secteur atteint presque 60 6%
en août les entreprises françaises sont
le premier employeur étranger en
fédération de russie plusieurs
entreprises emploient des dizaines de
milliers de personnes en russie a par
conséquent cela nécessite une
communication constante frappes au sol
une discussion constante sur les
questions qui apparaissent pour ce qui
est des 600 projets d'investissements
réalisés par des entreprises françaises
dans l'économie russe et des projets
assez important d'entreprises russes en
france certaines questions se posent
toujours par conséquent le dialogue est
très important
les liens économiques bilatéraux se
remettent peu à peu à des effets de la
pandémie sur quoi vont porter les futurs
investissements français en russie et
les investissements russes en france
vous savez quand on parle des
investissements français en russie
l'éventail est assez large de manière
générale ces investissements sont très
diversifiés d'abord il existe un certain
nombre de grandes entreprises qui
opèrent de manière très efficace s'ils
investissent réinvestissent constamment
en russie à minsk renault est l'un de
nos plus grands constructeurs
automobiles
quand je dis de nos constructeurs je
sous entends bien sûr franco russe même
si nous considérons avtovaz à laquelle
renault participent et apporte ses
innovations technologiques comme une
entreprise
il est très important que l'entreprise
exporte ce depuis des usines russes vers
d'autres pays il ya aussi danone qui
travaillent activement dans le domaine
des produits alimentaires et qui
développent des chaînes de production de
production complexe quand ils produisent
non seulement des produits finis mais
aussi des ingrédients
il y à auchan comme payet très actif et
développe un réseau de supermarchés ou
con comme c'est un géant de la
distribution
kun est aussi sur le point de lancer la
construction d'un site de production de
matériel agricole dans la région de
voronej
saint gobain qui envisage de s'implanter
à kemerovo pour produire des matériaux
de construction il ya beaucoup
d'exemples de ce genre
par ailleurs il existe bien entendu un
partenariat stratégique dans le domaine
du pétrole et du gaz total par exemple à
10% de l' usine de liquéfaction de gaz
arctic lng 2 pour ce sera une usine
dégageant l'une des empreintes carbone
les plus faibles
l'une des usines des plus respectueuses
de l'environnement en souvenir de sang
qu'elle va fabriquer ce produit est le
livre est partout dans le monde y
compris en europe
[Musique]
la coopération avec rosatom est en cours
il y à de nouveaux domaines de
coopération avec rosatom dans le pays un
projet sera notamment mise en oeuvre à
sakhaline avec la société française air
liquide pour produire de l'hydrogène à
destination de pays tiers et qui doit
aussi être utilisé dans l'économie de
l'extrême orient russe
il y a aussi une coopération de rosette
d'homme est ed est frustrant c'est une
coopération entre rjd la société russe
des chemins de fer et d'autres
entreprises françaises dans de nombreux
domaines campagne
cependant il est important de souligner
qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'investissements d'entreprises
françaises en russie et d'entreprises
russes en france
notre coopération un grand potentiel
pour explorer les marchés des pays tiers
et notre chef de file dans ce domaine et
c'est bien sûr l'entreprise rosatom qui
avec areva et framatome
participe activement à la construction
de centrales électriques dans des pays
comme la finlande la hongrie on parle
aussi de la turquie et est impliqué dans
d'autres projets donc ce sont des sujets
sur lesquels on avance une pop et qui
nous font acquérir de l'expérience en
même temps je dois dire que nous avons
discuté aujourd'hui de plusieurs de ces
sujets dans un format restreint avec
monsieur le maire mais il ya toujours
des questions il ya la question des
garanties celle du partage des risques
christine et ainsi de suite mais c'est
un dialogue que nous venons en
permanence nous essayons toujours de
trouver des solutions mutuellement
acceptables
on sait que le président emmanuel macron
a déclaré que la france construirait
deux nouvelles centrales nucléaires la
russie a une grande expérience dans ce
secteur est ce qu'il ya des perspectives
de développement de collaboration dans
ce domaine
il me semble que j'ai déjà répondu en
partie à cette question car rosatom et
les entreprises françaises qui
interagissent avec elles de manière très
étroite exploitent ensemble les marchés
de pays tiers ce qui leur donne
l'occasion de conjuguer leurs forces à
cage de mettre en commun quand le
meilleur de leurs technologies et
d'offrir ensemble le produit le mieux
adapté à disney mais là deux choses sont
à noter d'abord il faut encore parvenir
à la reconnaissance définitive de
l'énergie atomique qui est une énergie à
faible empreinte carbone c'est à dire
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre le principe
de neutralité technologique ceux dont la
russie ne cesse de parler ensuite il est
nécessaire d'avoir une répartition
correcte des risques dans ces projets
car les projets nucléaires sont toujours
des projets à long terme il nécessite
une compréhension claire
le partage des risques politiques des
risques commerciaux et x des risques
liés à la hausse des coûts de
construction
car ce n'est un secret pour personne le
souvent des contrats rigide des tracts
dans le contexte de ce bon lait
confrontés dans notre économie face à la
montée de l'inflation sont soumis à une
grande pression
il est très important que ces mécanismes
soient structurées flexible et stable
nantes europe mais l'expérience que nos
entreprises ont accumulé mon nom bien
content de cela donc oui je pense que
dans ce cas tu es passé le domaine où la
russie et la france peuvent dés doivent
coopérer dans l'intérêt des économies de
nos deux pays comme vous l'avait dit à
des entreprises françaises qui opère
efficacement qui font d'importants
profits en russie laura merling auchan
renault qui figurent parmi les dix plus
grandes entreprises étrangères
françaises quel avantage réel pour ces
entreprises françaises de venir
s'implanter en russie et comment vous
arrivez à maintenir cette attractivité
le premier avantage c'est que c'est un
grand marché il ne s'agit pas uniquement
du marché russe et du marché de l'union
eurasienne taris milices qui compte plus
de 180 millions de personnes plus les
pays observateurs à tarnac c'est le
premier point rallongé d'autre part
c'est un marché avec un bon taux de
rendement nuit car il est en pleine
croissance sig daft il représente
beaucoup d'opportunités et dans ce genre
de situation il ya toujours un bon taux
de rendement presbourg ensuite c'est une
base pour fabriquer des biens crac pour
les marchés des pays tiers à des coûts
raisonnables l'exemple de renault le
confirme c'est à dire que l'économie
russe est capable de produire des biens
compétitif les employés ils sont
compétents qui tient il maîtrise la
technologie
technique ce sont tout simplement des
gens intelligents ou
mais le plus important est probablement
la compréhension mutuelle impôts que les
entreprises se sentent à l'aise en froid
même si nous organisons régulièrement
des réunions auront lieu les entreprises
nous parle souvent des barrières qui
existent
certains domaines il pas lire des choses
qui doivent encore être améliorés les
clichés nous y passons beaucoup de temps
après cela ils disent qu'en effet la
russie est un pays extrêmement
confortable compréhensible et prévisible
pour carrefour un pays dans lequel ils
peuvent et doivent et vont continuer à
investir pour qui son prêche il me
semble que cela témoigne définitivement
de la confiance que les entreprises
françaises vont dans l'économie russe je
parle des entreprises qui sont vraiment
l'implanter dans le pays campagne et qui
exerce réellement leurs activités parce
que le contexte informationnel on peut
être différent ils possibles sanctions
annoncées par l'union européenne ou les
états unis sont elles une menace pour la
stabilité des relations économiques avec
la france
toute sanction toutes ces conversations
ont toujours un impact négatif non mais
l'économie russe est une économie très
puissante et très stable au cours de ces
dernières années de sanctions elle a
appris à se développer nous avons créé
des secteurs qui n'existait pas
auparavant c'est par exemple nous avons
fortement développé notre agriculture
notre industrie agroalimentaire et les
entreprises françaises qui ont également
participé elle même à celles qui
travaillent tant russie ils en ont
également bénéficié d'une certaine façon
par conséquent aucune sanction ne peut
limiter l'économie russe oui on peut la
gêne et on peut influencer le taux de
croissance chaque mais cela affecte
aussi le taux de croissance de la france
nous perdons des marchés pas seulement
dans nos pays respectifs
mais nous perdons ensemble l'opportunité
de coopérer et de conquérir des marchés
dans d'autres par conséquent toutes ces
sanctions toujours un impact négatif
nous avons besoin d'un dialogue normal
calme et de confiance c'est bien là
dessus que notre président assiste
toujours et c'est ce qu'il propose de
manière active nous sommes prêts à tous
les niveaux au niveau des entreprises
gouvernementales ministériel à
travailler et à expliquer notre position
hung c'est en menant un dialogue que
nous pouvons trouver une solution aux
problèmes les plus compliqués merci
maxime reshetnikov d'avoir répondu à
ercis je rappelle que vous êtes le
ministre russe du développement
économique c'est la fin de cette grande
interview merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
vous pourrez retrouver cette grande
interview sur nos réseaux sociaux mais
aussi sur le site internet arte france
ce point à tva très bientôt
[Musique]